Roosevelt: "We are now in this war,
We're all in it..
All the way.
Every single man, woman and child
..is a partner in the most tremendous under taking of our American history
but all of us can have that deep and permanent inner satisfaction,
that comes from doing the best we know how."
Let's hear it for Captain America!
It's not gonna be a safe landing, I gotta put her in the water!
Steve!
Nick Fury: "You've been asleep, Cap
For almost 70 years.."
You're here with a mission sir?
Captain America: "Trying to get me back in the world?"
Trying to save it.
Most of the intelligence community doesn't believe he exists
The ones that do call him the "Winter Soldier"
Bucky?!
Who the hell is Bucky?
BUCKY, NOW!
Black Widow: "He's credited with over two dozen assassinations
in the last 50 years."
Captain America: "You're a wanted man
..And they're not planning on taking you alive."
Black Widow: "I know how much Bucky means to you..
..stay out of this one.
Please,
You'll only make this worse."
Captain America: "You're saying you'll arrest me?"
Captain.. you seem a little defensive.
Well it's been a long day.
Captain America: "Sorry Tony.
You know I wouldn't do this if I had any other choice
But he's my friend"
So was I.
Captain America: "You gave me this mission..
This is how it ends."
Iron Man: "You just started a war!"
Iron Man: "You chose the wrong side."